well this doesn't sound like a confident
campaign Democrats are now asking
Hillary Clinton to save Joe Biden's
failing reelection prospects a brand new
poll shows Nikki Haley absolutely
clobbering Joe Biden by a whopping 17
points and former president Trump
defeating Biden by four points and with
numbers that bad panicked Democrats are
bringing in Hillary Clinton to boost his
campaign and become a key player in the
reelection effort last month Hill hosted
a fundraiser that raed in almost 1
million bucks for the big guys campaign
Hillary is not the only Democrat on the
case to save Joe Biden quote Clinton's
role is only expected to grow in the new
year but for now she is filling a space
that at a later point in the campaign
season former president Barack Obama
will join okay so um if we've got these
numbers where you know Nikki Haley is 17
points ahead and and uh you know Donald
Trump is four points ahead although you
know Nikki Haley's numbers I guess it
depends on the poll what is Hillary
Clinton going to do to save the day
Jesse she knows how to lose to Donald
Trump I wouldn't be asking her for much
advice she probably leaked that she's
going to be taking a bigger role in the
campaign she held a nice fundraiser at
chapaqua and she placed this in Politico
I don't know what really she adds but
you're right I think the Biden campaign
is in deep deep trouble
uh not only losing by four to Trump but
by how many 17 to Nikki and if you look
at those numbers you know she goes up a
little over to 51 more than Trump but a
lot of that deterioration are Democrats
not voting for Joe Biden and voting for
Nikki Haley and if you have the hunter
situation which is still percolating you
don't know how that's going to shake out
and the uh Oracle of Omaha dumping all
his stocks in the first three quarters
something could be not very good around
the corner okay all right well you know
Greg think of the fact that you know
Nikki Haley may be at 17 or whatever but
she's never making it out of the pack so
and with Donald Trump in Iowa I mean
he's crushing everybody in Iowa maybe
it's maybe it's about VP who knows too
soon to tell but if I were Joe Biden I
would be worried Hillary coming aboard
like you said she's not known for
winning elections this is kind of like
asking Sammy the bull to take care of
your loud
neighbor message to Joe if Hillary shows
up at the White House with a my pillow
it's not for
napping uh but I think I think I think
we should all be a little worried and
prepared for what's to come because even
when the Dems aren't painted in a COR
Corner they fight like they do they can
create a conflict to cause fear and
anxiety and outrage in order to keep
Republicans you know scared of of of
even you know voting uh and I think
they're in a terrible spot now hence the
green light for calling everybody Hitler
or or that Trump is going to end
democracy that again is to allow any
efforts legal or otherwise to destroy
the candid candidacy we've been watching
these marches that the protesters
screaming for genocide that's going to
morph it's going to morph into a
different kind of protest but with the
same Obsession it's going to go nuclear
but it won't just be anti-Semitism it's
going to be anti everybody who is not on
board
you know Harold if if Trump is beating
Biden uh On the Border by 30% inflation
by 21% the economy 177% what else
besides abortion does Biden have going
for him so having access to safe and
legal abortions has been the issue that
I think has confounded a lot of people
to how that issue alone if you look at
the data points four or five weeks ago
the I think three or four weeks ago the
elections and referendums as well as a
year ago with the with the midterms uh
it's unclear to me if that will sustain
itself through next year uh but
certainly Democrats and I believe the
White House believes that now I I don't
I've said for a while I don't believe
that the campaign for Mr Biden is fully
built out I don't think that they have
hired the number of people I need to
hire to to really have a full campaign
and if they have a strategy it's a
tightly held secret I think that one of
the things they need to do is to begin
campaigning in Earnest to talk about the
things in addition to Choice uh and
access to Safe illegal abortions that
the president has done and what he plans
to do going forward one of the
interesting things about all of this is
that it appears from some of the polling
um that the two most at least the most
dominant candidate on the Republican
side is not the front runner although
the front runner is three or four points
ahead uh but the most dominant candidate
Miss Haley when the head-to-head she's
the only one polling above 50 we all
know but Dan and I know in particular
having been in these campaigns being
being in the lead but not being above 50
is different when you're above 50 I
don't care if your lead's four points or
14 points it's a different way to run
it's a different way to run a campaign I
always thought in 16 that President
Trump then candidate Trump was going to
win because Mrs Clinton as much as she
was ahead of him she was never above 50
in any of the Battleground States so
here we are again today with both of
these the Two Front Runners hovering
somewhere in high 40s mid-40s uh and you
have another candidate that's way ahead
I think that as as we get closer here to
January 15th and January 23rd and
February 8th and February 23rd the dates
of some of the the important contest
early contest Republicans are going to
have a big choice to make do you take a
risk with the person who is a front
runner right now who's way ahead in the
polls who doesn't who's seemingly not at
50 and it's above but is running ahead
of President Biden or do you take a risk
on someone else who's way ahead of him
and then Democrats if Nikki Haley be
continues to to to pull well I know you
were looking at some the polling that if
she looks if she's going to win one of
the early States Democrats going to have
a hard question I don't know if it will
be Mrs Clinton but they're going to have
a hard question to answer do you stick
with this president if he continues to
be clobbered in the poles by Miss Haley
I don't know the answers to these things
but I do hope they get a strategy and
they start campaigning soon so but along
with what Harold's saying in Iowa
Trump's at 50 Haley's at 11 right and
then you've got what after that North
Carolina and a few other South Carolina
Nevada right but yeah it goes Iowa New
Hampshire South Carolina then Super
Tuesday but is like super mega Tuesday
there's all sorts of races that day so a
couple things so on Nikki Haley might
well not make it out of the primary she
might not even get to be uh the one
that's going head-to-head against
President Trump because Republican
voters typically are not persuaded by
electability but in those polls it shows
that if you are going to if you want to
beat Biden then you want to go against
Nikki Haley one of the reasons that the
that the Biden campaign perhaps
mistakenly has long wanted to run
against Trump again is because they know
that he would probably be beaten by
somebody else he also might be beaten by
somebody who from his own Camp RFK Jr
with the third party run getting 20% in
Michigan in the recent poll in addition
on the question of democracy of
protecting democracy Biden has only a
one-point lead over Trump in the Wall
Street Journal poll okay so people are
concerned about the future of democracy
for different reasons but also a similar
type of thing um the other point I would
make about Hillary Clinton if I could so
one of the problems for Biden is that
younger people are unenthusiastic about
him and they're really against his
defense of Israel do you think bringing
Hillary Clinton on is going to help that
situation absolutely not but it might
help him keep more Democrats in his Camp
because if he goes too far to the
progressives on the Israel Hamas Gaza
question then he's going to alienate
them but where Hillary Clinton could be
effective is on abortion and that is the
play that the Democrats are going to run
in all 50 states no matter what and some
of these states have really important
referendum so she could possibly be
helpful there but not on a big scale
yeah and it's a question of the where
they put it on a referendum and whether
or not it is an issue in a lot of States
hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now